digamos que tenemos una función f la
cual va a ir de x va a ir de x allí así
que voy a dibujar un conjunto x por aquí
digamos que este es nuestro conjunto x
algo así y sabemos que como lo hemos
hecho en vídeos anteriores una función
simplemente va a asociar cada elemento
de nuestro conjunto x a el conjunto y el
conjunto y entonces digamos que este es
un elemento de nuestro conjunto x y
aplicamos la función a x o si estamos
trabajando con vectores podemos imaginar
que en lugar de usar la palabra función
usaríamos la palabra transformación pero
bueno es lo mismo nosotros asociaremos
con este elemento de nuestro conjunto x
el conjunto y así que a esto le llamamos
mapeo cuando a este elemento le
aplicamos la función
diferente color es lo que estoy
asociando el pequeño elemento o miembros
de aquí ve x al que llamaremos a lo
vamos a mapear o lo vamos a asociar con
un elemento en nuestro conjunto y
entonces digamos que nuestro alimento
pertenece al conjunto x y al aplicarle
la función a vamos a llegar a be será
igual a b y por supuesto esto es lo que
hemos estado aprendiendo acerca de
funciones ahora definiré una pareja
interesante de funciones la primera y
ésta es sólo una función inmenso
mencioné una pareja porque llamaremos a
la función identidad
vamos a llamar primeramente a la función
identidad y dicha función
la renombrar hemos con una mayúscula y
esta función identidad opera en un
conjunto al que digamos que sería x esta
función identidad en x irá de x
a x donde a es un elemento de x por lo
que al hacer la identidad a nuestro
elemento a que es un elemento de x será
igual a por lo que literalmente lo que
hace nuestra función identidad es solo
mapear o asignar las cosas a sí mismas
así que nuestra función identidad si la
estuviéramos dibujando en este diagrama
de aquí luciría algo así luciría como lo
puse con este otro color sería como una
especie de círculo que solo pone de
regreso al punto donde este inicio pues
asocia todos los puntos consigo mismos y
esta es la función identidad en x y en
este caso particular lo que nos resulta
es aplicarla al punto a y esto es
nuestra función identidad en x y pues
también tener una función identidad de
jeff así que digamos que b es un miembro
de ayer el cual dibuje por aquí y al
hacer su función identidad en que se
comportaría de esa forma como lo dibujé
en verde luego la función identidad de y
será la función identidad aplicada a b
que va a definirse a sí mismo va a
referirse a sí mismo por lo que esto va
a ser igual a b y esta es la función
identidad de i y tal vez podrías decir
hey estas son unas funciones un tanto
bodas pues como para que las podría usar
pero en realidad estas tienen una
anotación importante y demasiado útil
para cuando tenemos casos en álgebra
lineal pero ahora haré una nueva
definición diré que una función
es digamos que una función
invertible es una función invertible y
es una nueva terminología si y sólo si
se cumple lo siguiente entonces es
verdadero si se cumple lo siguiente
puedes poner si solo si con estas
flechas o s&w y te estás refiriendo que
si se cumple una condición entonces
cumple la siguiente y viceversa así que
si fs invertible estoy haciendo una
especie de definición por aquí entonces
f es invertible si y sólo si existe una
función que aún no la he nombrado y la
llamaré en un momento a la cual le
pondremos efe a la menos uno o efe a la
super índice menos uno así que f es
invertible si y sólo si existe una
función inversa que es como la acabo de
nombrar f inversa de tal forma de tal
forma que deja lo escribo en otro color
color morado creo que resulta bien
si aplico fs aplicamos efe recuerde que
f simplemente está mapeando o asociando
de x allí por lo que esta función f
inversa va a mapear o asociar de iu a x
y lo que estoy diciendo es que f es
invertible si existe una función f
inversa que está mapeando de iu a x de
forma de que si tomo la composición de f
inversa con efe esto va a ser igual a la
identidad a la función identidad sobre
el conjunto x así que pensemos acerca de
qué es lo que está pasando con esta
parte entonces solo déjame completar
toda la definición esto es verdad y esto
tiene que ser verdad porque la
composición de f con f inversa y la
composición de f
efe inversa será igual a la función
identidad sobre i
y ahora sí pensemos en lo que esto nos
está diciendo hay alguna función que voy
a llamar ahora mismo que es la inversa
de f la inversa de f y está asociada
está asociando de equis y déjame
dibujarlo por aquí arriba la inversa de
f
y estamos diciendo que debe haber otra
función efe inversa que me pedía x por
lo que la escribiré aquí efe inversa es
un mapeo de ella x con lo que f inversa
nos dará algún valor en el conjunto y y
voy a y lo voy a llevar al conjunto de x
por lo que este dominio y este otro co
dominio por acá este es el co dominio y
este otro sería el dominio y bueno
simplemente va cambiando a veces uno es
el dominio y otro es el co dominio
dependiendo si es
efe efe inversa pero bueno es suficiente
ahora veamos que nos está diciendo nos
dice que la composición de f inversa con
f
tendrá que ser igual a la matriz
identidad perdón a la función identidad
por lo que esencialmente dice que si
aplicamos efe a algún valor en x piensa
en esta composición que es lo que nos
dice bien lo que nos dice es que algunos
elementos van de x allí y otros
elementos en la f inversa van de gea x
sólo es cuestión de pensar en qué está
pasando
efe irá de equis ayer y luego f inversa
será o irá de iu a x por lo que nuestra
composición va a ir de x x que es lo que
esta función identidad está mapeando o
es lo que nos está diciendo es lo mismo
que hacer la composición de f con f
inversa que la identidad entonces
necesitas ir de ekiza x entonces estás
diciendo que esta función será igual a
la identidad por lo que significa que
cuando apliques efe en algún valor de
nuestro dominio y luego le aplicas f
inversa a ese punto de ahí irás de
regreso al punto original así que otra
forma de hacer esto es moviéndonos y
decir esto de aquí déjame lo pongo de
otro color que f inversa compuesta con
efe aplicado a un elemento de x que
sería a será igual a la identidad en el
conjunto x de a lo cual va a ser igual a
nuestro punto inicial que es
entonces dicha composición f inversa
para f
va a ser igual a y esto todo esto es lo
que nos dice nuestro primer enunciado y
si lo piensas o lo hacemos visualmente
por aquí tenemos
efe de a efe de a y luego le aplicas f
inversa a este elemento
efe inversa a ese elemento entonces
vamos a ir ahora de equis y entonces
llegamos a este primer elemento que es
lo que hicimos con la identidad si lo
recuerdas por ahí está marcada para ver
la identidad pues si aplicas f inversa
que no siempre va a existir pero si
aplicas f inversa a esta función vas a
tener que regresar al punto inicial por
definición
necesitas regresar a su original a esto
tendrá que ser igual o equivalente a
hacerlo un poco más de cerca vamos a
hacer un bucle más cerrado y entonces
esto es lo que nos hacía nuestra función
identidad entonces aquí tenemos
efe inversa de un elemento en b que
digamos que es jeff y entonces al
aplicarle ahora la función normal
efe normal que va de x ahí nos va a
regresar a este punto oye que ese
elemento de nuestro conjunto y y es lo
mismo que la identidad de i
y es justamente lo que nuestro segundo
enunciado nos está diciendo ahora si
aplicamos
efe efe inversa de nuestro elemento y
donde ya es un elemento de nuestro
conjunto y esto va a ser igual a nuestro
punto inicial que era allí y tú ya
tenías el concepto o la definición de
función inversa antes sólo que aquí lo
estoy haciendo un poco más preciso
porque empezamos a trabajar más en este
tipo de notaciones para las
transformaciones y matrices que vamos a
ver en un futuro muy cercano y bueno
ahora algo interesante por preguntarnos
digamos que tenemos
efe nuestra función y que existe f
inversa la cual satisface 2 estas dos
proposiciones y una pregunta obvia o
quizás no tan obvia pero realmente
interesante sería preguntarnos efe
inversa es única y quizás se te haga una
pregunta un tanto obvia pero lo
interesante es más bien saber
efe es invertible entonces
efe a la menos 1 f invertible es única
realmente resulta muy interesante por lo
que para resolver o contestarnos dicha
pregunta vamos a suponer que no es única
por lo que si no es única entonces
digamos que existen dos funciones dos o
más funciones que van a satisfacer
nuestras proposiciones que puedan actuar
como la f inversa por lo que digamos que
g es una de ellas
al ser una de las funciones inversas
entonces va a ir de y ax se va a ir de y
ax y entonces si aplicamos o hacemos la
composición de gdf compuesta con g
entonces vamos a ir de x a x que es lo
mismo que si escribimos nuestra función
identidad sobre x
y viene entonces al cumplir con que f
compuesta con es igual a la identidad de
nx nos lleva a ser parte de la
definición de lo que es una inversa
entonces estoy asumiendo que g es la
inversa de f a la hora de asumir que es
inversa de f entonces implican ambas
proposiciones ahora que es inversa de f
y digamos que existe h que h es otra
inversa de nuestra función f que va a ir
de iu a x entonces h es otra es otra
inversa de f entonces por definición a
lo que llamamos inversa de f es porque
satisface las dos proposiciones entonces
tiene que ir de iu a x y que sea la
identidad al componer la con nuestra
función
f entonces bueno esta parte de la
definición implica más que eso pues si
algo es una inversa tiene que satisfacer
ambas proposiciones que la composición
de la inversa con la función
en la identidad del conjunto sobre x y
luego que la composición de la inversa
con la identidad se torna en la función
identidad sobre ella pero vamos a
escribirlo entonces digamos que f g
compuesta con f va a ser igual a la
función identidad sobre i a la función
identidad sobre ella y luego si hacemos
esto con h el factor de h es la inversa
de f que implica que la composición de f
con h es igual a la identidad sobre i
y una vez más déjame reescribirlo que
dibuje en un inicio para ver qué es lo
que estamos haciendo tenemos por aquí
nuestro conjunto x luego nuestro
conjunto y sabemos que se va y hace un
mapeo de x ayer
mateo de ekiza y es cierto y que la
inversa va a ir de equis
y qué es lo que hace que la inversa
digamos que tiene que ser única bien lo
que sucede es que si tomamos que que
digamos que es la situación donde al
componer la con efe obtendremos la
identidad por lo que f hace lo siguiente
entonces si tomamos que y vamos a
regresar al mismo punto al hacer la
composición con efe es lo equivalente a
decir que es lo que está haciendo la
identidad entonces tomando la
composición de g con f
esto es efe primero y luego g es
equivalente a solo tomar la función
identidad de x
esto es está en las equis y regresar a
las equis que es lo que estación esa
composición y si observas h efe
compuesta con h hace exactamente lo
mismo hace exactamente lo mismo y luego
veamos qué pasa si tomamos un elemento
en ye y aplicamos g entonces hacemos que
compuesta con efe y regresamos al punto
inicial entonces al re aplicar
efe entonces estamos haciendo la
identidad de y la identidad de ye que
estaría por aquí pero no nada más pasa
eso al hacer que compuesta con f sino
también al hacer h compuesta con f
o sea g y h al componer las con efe
están actuando de la misma forma así que
ahora regresemos a nuestra pregunta
original en que si f inversa es única o
la función inversa es única podemos en
realidad tener dos funciones inversas
diferentes una g y otra h que en
realidad hacen lo mismo
así que empecemos con g recuerda que es
un mapeo de ya x por lo que la función
que va a ser igual a g
compuesta con la identidad en x y para
mostrarte por qué pasa esto hay diagrama
volvió a ser confuso entonces volvamos a
hacer un dibujo de esto para que nos
podamos desplazar cómodamente sin
confundirnos entonces decimos que es
igual a g compuesta con la identidad
porque la identidad lo que está haciendo
es lo siguiente que va de iu a x
entonces tomamos un elemento en y va a x
y al componer la con la identidad se
vuelve a quedar en este mismo elemento x
que es lo que en realidad hace la
función por sí misma por lo que esto es
válido pues la identidad lo único que
nos está haciendo es regresar la función
al mismo lugar entonces estas son
equivalentes pero también otra forma de
hacer esto es que podemos escribirlo de
otra forma podemos escribir que esto
también es igual
efe compuesta con h compuesta con g y
como vimos en vídeos anteriores las
composiciones son asociativas por lo que
puedes poner aquí unos paréntesis
imaginarios y al decir que son
asociativas podemos escribirlo también
de la siguiente forma lo voy a escribir
por abajo aquí tenemos primero que
estará compuesta de esta composición
pero también es equivalente a que se
escribimos h compuesta con fe con f
compuesta con g
estas son equivalentes y para qué me
sirve esto bien pues vamos a ver qué
sucede la composición de f con g bien lo
habíamos dicho anteriormente y lo
definimos como la identidad sobre y
entonces esto va a ser igual a la
función identidad sobre james y ahora a
que será esto igual a la identidad de
compuesta con h
recuerda h es una función que va de guía
x entonces déjame dibujarlo este es mi
xy este es mi ley y tomando un elemento
de jeff lo manda a x como un elemento en
jeff y lo mandó a x y xi ahora tomamos
la composición la composición con la
identidad en que esto va a estar tomando
un elemento en y luego le aplica la
función identidad de niell nos deja el
elemento de y a esto fue lo que le
aplicamos h por lo que es lo mismo que
simplemente hubiéramos aplicado h que
fue con lo que iniciamos así que habrá
yendo a través del ejercicio con el que
iniciamos diciendo que teníamos estas
dos
inversas nos muestra que tiene que ser
la misma que h por lo que la función f
efe inversa única pues no puede tener
dos diferentes inversas hacen lo mismo
si llegaras a encontrar alguna otra debe
de ser la misma así que finalmente
sabemos que tienen una inversa que la
función f tiene una inversa y también
debemos pensar que es única y nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo espero haya sido
útil todo esto